If you are not actively vocally opposed
to this, you are scum. You are dirt.
This guy is one of the most wretched,
hypocritical, evil pieces of mine. For
what? For the benefit of him. For the
benefit of Israel. For what? For what?
It is landscape changing.
>> Destiny made it clear he didn't believe
it. He was just doing it to be an
>> encourage that hate. Feed it.
>> I think you're following. We come from
the Nicholas Dioro school of female
interaction. I see. Then Smaggle here
noticing that Nicholas Dioro has
retweeted this. So what's going on here?
Bo Blacks has been celebrating the Kilo
video in the last few days, guys.
Celebrating and shilling the Kilo video.
Uh saying that it Nick Dior will never
react to it because it exposes how he
lies for money. Which is true. Which
very true. Now, Bobie says here, "I
don't mind people on me for stuff I've
done because I did do a lot of things,
but Nicholas Dioro in particular is
objectively a bad narrator and a liar.
Even someone like or RFC, for example,
as mean as he is, will say what he
really believes and won't lie. I hope
more people realize this bad behavior
and be aware of it, even if they do
continue to watch him. I'm glad it's
happening a bit with people taking
notice on how he tactfully avoided
holding H2O accountable for copyright
striking. At least Hilo's video on him
was so good." confusing opinion here.
Says, "Didn't you claim that Nicholas
Dorio was common cop with no evidence?"
So, no rebuttal. No rebuttal. Just
crying about Bobi. This guy is like
legit like, "Man, this is another guy
where it's like I fear this may be a
bobby. I fear confusing opinion that you
may be a Bob and you don't realize it
because I've seen this guy and he's like
some gigger autistic like 300 pound dude
and I don't so I don't know why he goes
out of his way to stick his neck out and
look like a deflecting from valid
criticisms for the sake of for the sake
of Nick. You are like literally they
would sell you out in a second because
you're an embarrassing just like Bobby.
You're like, you know, risk of transing.
Risk of transing. That's how they
evaluate you. But for some reason, you
always see this guy come out with like
the most vapid like Diorio sweep tweets
you've ever seen. I'm pretty sure I've
seen him do it before. It's just totally
embarrassing. It's like, you're a loser,
bro. You're a loser. You're like a
nobody hanger on read and you stick your
neck out to defend this idiot who's
lying. What an what an embarrassing
situation to be in. Truly, what an
embarrassing situation. So, Smaggle
quote tweets with a screenshot here.
Nicholas Dorio retweeted that. Um,
because obviously he he's not he can't
even fight Bobi himself, guys. He can't
even fight Bobi himself anymore. He has
to have uh some 300 pound orbiter do it
for him. Uh, so Smuggle here says as
well, Nick tried to ban Boax in his
chat. I said nigh nigh. So, here we go.
Boax says, "React to Kilo's video
segment on you." Bob was hidden by the
Oreo. Bob was unhidden by Smagwood. Wy
Wyan, let's go. Let's go, Wyan. Let's
go. We love Wyan. That's huge. So,
that's pretty awesome. That's pretty
awesome stuff. So, that brings us guys
to Ethan's latest announcement. Now, I
haven't covered this whole story about
Ethan being super I think I watched a
clip. Ethan being super weird to that
Russian woman. And I haven't covered
Ethan obsessing over Ana Joe Mahar's
[__] hair either, which he did for an
extended period of time on his on his
podcast today. Um, however, that's
because of something far worse going on,
guys. Uh, he has sent a cease and assist
to Idubbbz, guys. He has sent a cease
and desist to Idubbbz and is bragging
about how he's going to sue him or how
he could sue him. Let's What What's the
reason for that, guys? He's fat tired.
True.
>> Only cuz you're here.
>> He's fat tired. He's poor. It's a bad
harvest. He's breastfeeding a baby. Oh
god.
>> You You usually breastfeed babies.
>> No, you bro.
>> I read I know you.
>> She's tired.
>> He's He's filling in.
You You know how it ends.
>> The book. Yeah. Yeah, I do know how it
ends.
>> What's a book? Sorry. Sorry. I shouldn't
have done that. I didn't mean to tease
you like that.
>> That's all right.
No one wants to be around this guy.
Nobody wants to be around this guy.
>> Um I'm still mad that you called me an
[__] I think I'm lashing out.
>> Good to uh work through how you're
feeling.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Um I guess what they do in
their free time is uh is up to them, but
I need to move on. I need to do other
[__] Mhm.
>> I understand how hard it is to get
attention online when you're not relying
on kind of the easy [__] And the easy
[__] is like rolling around in drama.
>> Yeah. Well, even when you were saying
I'm a a molester of my children, I mean,
[__] was pop. You were you were popping
off with like a thousand Denny patrons.
That was, you know,
>> it was a good time.
>> So, let me tell you a little story. The
second Idubbbz stopped talking about us
happened to coincide
when I um
took into my um service some fine
Canadian lawyers.
That's right. Um so guys, you may be
thinking, "Oh, what could what could
Ethan be suing Idubbbz for? What could
Ethan be suing What has IDubb possibly
done? What did he do? He used some of
Ethan's content in his in his content
cop, but that was that was totally fair
use. And Ethan wouldn't launch an actual
lawsuit or file CND over that surely.
You know, striking a Reddit post from an
anonymous user is one thing. It would be
incredibly stupid to file a big public
lawsuit over something like that against
another creator. That would be that
would be very stupid. So, it can't be
that. I wonder what it is. I wonder what
it is.
>> Lawyers that specialize in defamation.
And by the way,
>> what defamation? I really don't think
that's
>> So, how did Idubbbz defame Ethan? Is it
because he didn't mention CPS in his
content cop? Is it because he because he
said Ethan was upset but didn't mention
CPS in his content cop? Do we think? I
don't think that could be defamatory. No
lawyer no lawyer would take that surely.
>> Okay. Thing to put out. some fine
Canadian um defamation lawyers that sent
a letter to Ana
and uh Ian demanding
a retraction and a halting
of uh of the defamatory statements that
I molest my children. And the day after
that,
the school
>> So did you hear that? The claim that he
molests his children. the claim that he
molests his children. Was it Idubbbz who
said that? Was it Idubbbz who said that?
I don't remember Idubbbz saying that. I
don't remember Idubbbz saying that. Now,
what I do remember is Idubbbz as a bit
to [__] with Ethan because Ethan is
[__] terrified of going against
Destiny because he got a bunch of [__]
for it last time and you realize that it
weakens his position. Hence why he only
goes after people on the pro Palestine
side. Hopefully, we're we're seeing the
the very clear pattern arising in
Ethan's behavior here when he realized
that he can't go after people on his own
side because it damages him because
that's where his support is. That's
where his base is. Because he got all of
his talking points against Assan for
like a [__] year from that subreddit
because Destiny actively told his
community to engage with Ethan's
community to take their place to
supplant them to convince him that
Hassan was anti-semitic. Because he even
realized he couldn't go against Destiny.
Idubbbz started putting a little message
from Destiny up on the screen whenever
thought Ethan might review his content
where Destiny said Ethan Klein is a
pedophile who molests his children. So
Ethan to stop Idubbbz going after him
has issued a cease and desist for
something Destiny said that Idubbbz was
using as an on-screen element as a joke.
Orch Lagoon was slaying
like smog. One, there was only one scale
shown and it was the threat of a
lawsuit.
>> And if any
like Nicholas Dioro are supporting this
or not, not not even just supporting it.
If you are not actively vocally opposed
to this, you are scum. You are dirt and
no one is going to forget it. You're
never going to forget it. I will make
[__] sure of it. That's right.
It's not because they're principled.
It's not because he's above it. In fact,
they're hurting bad. Look at him. His
[__] is [__] falling off so hard.
It's crazy how hard it's falling off.
Yeah. No, this ain't going to fly, scum.
This is not going to fly. You fat
[__] degenerate. I can't for the life
of me fathom why it would be a flex to
cease and desist two poor losers in
Canada over them showing a comment of a
completely different person said without
pursuing destiny. Sorry, I just don't
know what's to be gained in the
situation. How anyone would look at this
and go, "Wow, that's a win." Lau, it's
also kind of sad because in isolation, I
thought Ian apologizing was the first
good move he made. And now I'm realizing
it was a [__] CN D. Lauizing
to Ethan was a good move. For what?
For what? For what? You fat. What should
he apologize for? What the [__] should
he apologize for? Nothing. Nothing. You
are dirt. You are human. This guy has
been going on about Idubbbz's wife for
how [__] long. And Idubbbz makes some
jokes back at him and he's supposed to
apologize. You're human. You are human.
You are genuinely human. It's
disgusting. Apologizing for not or maybe
saying apologize for not mentioning CPS
in the video. He was saying that. That's
even dumber. That's even dumber. That is
literally even dumber. if he is
literally I'm CPS CPS CPSing in this
tweet. Prison. [__] prison. Public
trial in prison. Seriously,
I'm not kidding. What's this? Yeah.
Literally. Literally. You You are here.
You are here. You are here, guys. Take a
[__] stand. Seriously, below [__]
dirt.
>> It was literally the day he stopped
talking about it, right? He doesn't talk
about the snark anymore. He doesn't talk
about me anymore. And um there by the
way desperately unfort this this is the
ultimate irony and I love this. America
love America.
>> Also uh full aggression on clips guys.
Full aggression on clips. Full
aggression on clips.
>> If he lived in California, I wouldn't
even bother threatening to sue him
because of because in our great
>> very important month, guys. It's a very
important month
>> and Ethan is only making it more
important and so is this [__]
disgusting fat [__]
>> that make it extraordinarily difficult
to sue um public figures for defamation
and we have this extreme appreciation
for for free speech and the first
amendment. Now let me tell you something
Ian he hates America. He wants
>> Thank you for the membership for our
flight. Thank you
>> ways possible. He thinks this place
sucks. So he moved to the to the
northern wall and pledged to the night
watch.
But let me tell you something about uh
Canada,
the North
defamation laws ain't quite the same up
there. And when I spoke to an attorney
about it and showed it to him, they're
like, "Yeah, no. This this is quite bad.
This is definitely actionable here in
Canada. In America, in California, you
could say that. Could have said that.
But in Canada,
>> why do you think we do our show here?
>> Exactly.
You think I could do this show in
Edmonton?
>> I'd be ruined.
>> Be ruined.
>> Yeah. It's almost like you're using
you're exploiting asymmetrical standards
to silence people talking [__] about you
in the same way you would about them.
Right. Disgusting filth. Truly, what
this guy is one of the most wretched,
hypocritical, evil pieces of [__] online
and this scum [__] Dioro has spent a
[__] year, two years, three years
meat riding it. It's truly [__]
disgusting. You know that? You can talk
all the [__] on Idubbbz. You [__]
want this. Literally nothing will make
me want to rally behind this stupid
[__] yo worthless ineffectual [__]
coward Idubbbz than some disgusting
piece of [__] like this trying to shut
him up. Truly [__] wretched man. You
belong in seriously that is where no one
should send you there but after you die
you belong in you truly do. You truly
deserve for an eternity. You you should
wake up every I say wake up. You'll
always be awake. It'll be eternal.
BURNING FLAMES JUST LIKE AH AH I'M BEING
WHIPPED BY DEMONS. AH BURNING FL for the
rest for the rest of your existence.
>> Exactly. You were so desperate to get
away from America.
But now that you're in Canada,
>> seriously, there is literally nothing
wrong than some old [__] pervert like
this desperately trying to shut people
up. It's so [__] disgusting. It's so
[__] disgusting, man.
>> I found me a Canadian lawyer who's
pretty gung-ho about suing you.
>> And I might just do that.
>> And you know, he's growling.
>> Wait, but he's he's apologized.
>> Yeah, but the damage is done. So this
apology was not because I see people
they're taking this to mean that you
threatened them and that in response
he's apologizing. No, he's
>> in talks.
>> Oh, okay.
>> They're desperate to prevent litigation.
>> Gotcha.
>> And they've preempted.
>> So again, trying to extort a settlement
agreement under insane financial
pressure using an asymmetrical standard
to go after something that you do
yourself. You're totally happy to use
these sorts of tactics as other people
to shut someone up because they went
against you. You're scum. You're filth.
You spent the whole [__] last two
years make well sorry last year for
these two making obsessive sexual
comments about his wife and now you're
trying to sue him for making a joke
referencing something. He's not even
joking about you molesting your kids.
He's joking about the fact someone said
you molested your kids and you're too
[__] to go after them and you're too
much of a wretched amoral [__] to go
after them and you just collect a bunch
of other wretched amoral [__]
Nicholas Dioro Loner Box to do your
[__] dirty work for you. I hear Loner
Box is is tacitly defending this. I hear
I hear his chat filled him in in on some
of the information and he decides to go
oh what? Sorry, what did he say? There
was some [__] about how um Ethan and
Destiny both called each other
pedophiles so he can't go after him or
something like that. [__] idiot.
Idiot.
>> He apologized out of
>> Do how much reading on Canadian
defamation law did you do for that?
Probably about as much as you did for
plausibility and risk. I imagine that's
a that's a joke. That's a joke. Me and L
still argue about that. Okay.
>> Pure um patheticness. But you know in my
opinion because we there's no agreement.
You just want to go I'm so sorry.
Please, my principles.
>> Be sorry. Think [__] second.
>> Exactly. Thank you, Christopher. [__]
legend.
>> Christian.
>> Christian. Christopher. WE'RE ON CLOSER
TERMS.
>> OH, GOOD FOR YOU.
>> SO, UM,
so I might Yeah. So, the defamation's
already happened. We sent him a letter
saying like, "Hey, you got to stop
because your dam the damages are just
mounting up." And they stop desperately
stopped, right? and they got a lawyer
and now we're just talking. I don't want
to give away the details of our
settlement because I'm I am I'm way
above that, right, Dan?
>> You're above giving details of the
>> I respect the Canadian legal system with
the utmost care and respect.
>> I see.
>> And
>> you're not supposed to share any details
is what
>> I would never I would never. The crown
would never.
>> You usually share everything. So that
doesn't sound right at all.
>> I respect the crown.
>> Okay. So it sounds like because you're
not allowed to. not allowed to is one
thing, but I just respect the crown.
>> Okay, got it.
>> But I will say that um I think I'm going
to do it right because the damages,
right, to my reputation are um are
terrible. I feel terribly damaged. Um
and there's actually such a crazy funny
thing about the Canadian thing too cuz
he moved to Canada.
>> Look,
this is so telling
>> running from Bo Blacks. Ethan feels no
need to even attempt to justify or
create an air of justification anymore
because he has assumed that the people
defending him will go to the ends of the
earth. He feels no need to because he's
already lied, cheated, scammed, [__] you
over so many times if you're an Ethan
Klein supporter. Told you that he's
launch told you that he's what? Um,
you're so upset by the way Denims has
has gone after him and and saying that
she directly was involved in CPS and
they had to walk it back. They had to
walk it back. You literally you got
scammed in supporting this insane
[__] campaign. You got scammed in
supporting the ADL and he doesn't feel
any need to justify himself anymore. He
feels no need to say it anyway. He feels
no need to even pretend because why
would Dioro flip now? Why would Dioro
flip now? It doesn't make any sense for
him to flip now. Obviously, we know why
Dioro would flip now. It's because
criticism of him is reaching a fever
pitch. It's because even his closest
ex-loss allies, closest allies like
Smaggle, Boak's ex-loss ally are saying,
"You're caught. You're [__] caught.
You have nowhere to go. You're
red-handed. You lied. You supported
something against your principles.
You've abandoned everything we used to
claim to be." So, why the [__] would
Ethan think Nick isn't going to support
this? Even now, Nick refuses vocal
opposition. Nick is instead focusing on,
"Oh, this isn't really a win. Why are
you flexing this?" No. Vocal opposition.
Show there is still like anything left
in you, you [__] husk. Vocal
opposition. This guy is honestly Idubbbz
calling Ethan Klein a pedophile is too
kind. This guy is far worse than a
[__] pedophile. This guy is something
far worse than a [__] pedophile. The
way this guy acts, the amount of people
he's having impact on right now, the
fact he may totally [__] up free speech,
not just online, but more broadly, for
what? For the benefit of him, for the
benefit of Israel, for what? For what?
This is like legitimately, if some of
these lawsuits go through, it is
landscape changing [__] It is landscape
changing [__] It will affect all of the
content you watch. And this was known
back in the day. You'll hear Dioro
himself banging on about how much of an
issue this is for the ecosystem, the
landscape, how this will focus all over
endlessly. You'll hear him banging on
about this in old videos and what has he
been doing for the whole last two years,
lying about false DMCAs. C saying that
people don't deserve free speech if
they're mean to him. And now this, and
now this tepid, I don't think this is a
wing. I I don't think this is a win. I
don't think this is a flex. Why are you
flexing this? You're going to jail,
buddy. You're going to jail.
Radio head parallel Android. That one
line. Okay. I learned you can't even
crowdfund.
>> You will be first
>> in Canada for lawsuits.
>> And you can't you
>> why? So I I'm not sure on the exact law,
but if he did crowdfund, they'd have to
basically ID and verify the identity of
every single person that gives money.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So you're going to [__] jail, buddy.
You're going to jail
>> to, you know, do something like that on
GoFundMe.
>> You're going to what prison?
>> So they're not even capable of
crowdfunding for this. the fact that he
they moved to the camp. Why would they
have to?
>> I am committing $50 to Idubbbz and
GoFundMe before they've even launched
it. I'm publicly stating I will donate
$50 to the Idubbbz GoFundMe to fight
Ethan Klein in court.
>> Do that. Idubbbz is a really successful
YouTuber.
>> You're right.
>> Probably got a lot of money, right?
>> Yes.
>> No, you're you're right. I I assume a
lot of people would want to support
them. That's all.
>> How about 500?
>> Didn't I hear that?
>> True, true. I would. True. Idubbbz, put
up another video. Why don't you go fun
me? I'll I'll be paying. I'll be paying.
[__] this guy. [__] I don't even [__]
with Idubbbz anymore. You know, I
understand some people are pretend like
some [__] you know, like I would
defend Idubbbz. I think Idol's like
[__] awesome or something. I don't
like Idubbbz. Idubbbz [__] sucks.
He's an in effectual worthless loser.
But holy [__] is this would this be
worth fighting? It just would. It's
[__] disgusting. It's truly
disgusting
>> that they never have to work another day
in their life. Ana said that recently.
>> Let's give it up.
>> Sounds like they're pretty lucky.
>> True. Right.
So, um should be
>> Yeah,
>> no problem.
>> Should be no problem for them.
>> But, um at at any rate, uh this is about
look, this is about protecting my family
and my reputation, you know, and the
fact that he moved to Canada was was a
5D chess play um uh against himself,
>> right? Very good. So, I'm very happy he
moved to Canada. I'm glad to know that
we have the best and brightest
protecting us in the north.
>> Winter is coming.
>> I'm a woke dragon
>> and I wish you guys the best. I really
do.
>> I really, really do.
>> Can I ask? So, why you know I didn't
follow all this. What what what's the
deal with this Destiny connection?
>> The quote was a Destiny quote,
>> right? But the thing is, Destiny made it
clear he didn't believe it. He was just
doing it to be an [__]
>> Got it. What is this [__] excuse,
man? What is You know, he repeated it
numerous times, Ethan. He's repeated it
numerous times. You're a [__] [__]
You're a disgusting [__] [__] You
are truly one of the most lowlife
[__] online. It's disgusting. I went
against this perverted.
I'm a [__] nobody. I've got no way to
fight. You're a [__] [__] This
guy's coming after your family. This
guy's saying you your kids. You are a
disgusting [__] who doesn't care about
his family and only gives a [__] about
looking cool online. You care about
getting support from Asminold. You care
about getting support from Nick Dioro.
You don't give a [__] about anything
else. It's some of the most disgusting
[__] [__] in the world. You just want
the [__] Tik Tok horse back. Be
honest, bro. Right. Idubbbz. Who knows?
>> That banner that was just like a
statement.
>> Just a quote with
>> Guys, it's only defamation if you
believe it's true. Okay, that's Ethan
Klein's new standard. It's only
defamation if you believe it's true.
>> Text that says
>> Desi didn't mean it. Desi didn't believe
it.
>> Ethan Klein molests his children,
>> right?
>> And he and then Idubbbz put that as a
watermark for his whole episode and it's
like, man, this is a really serious
accusation. He should really address
this. Right.
>> And so I'm down to clown.
>> That is some 40 chess for sure.
>> Yeah. And I'm down to clown and be silly
and talk [__] and roll around in the pig
[__] But
>> so Ethan's justification is that Idubbbz
said this is a really serious
allegation. I think Ethan should address
it. That's that's apparently saying it's
true in some way. That may that means
it's now causing damage to Ethan.
>> Everybody, not just myself, everybody
when they saw that was like, "Dude,
you've lost your mind. This is too far.
You've gone, you've gotten snark brained
>> and the booger pose
>> and look and the desperate attempts to
try and create consent for it. Come in,
manufacture consent for it. He's snark
brain, guys. Remember I told you Snork's
bad? I told you snark's bad. I told you
snark's bad. No, Ethan. Actually, Snark
is just. Snock is just Card Posting had
a great quote about this. Actually, Card
Post had a great quote about this. Let's
pull it from the Kilo video real quick.
Let's pull it from the Kilo video
against
There's some people out there in the
world who think it's just inherently
wrong or regressive or childish to hate
people or to rail against public figures
online or whatever. And those people are
wrong. Wrong and just trying to run
cover for all the other people in the
world who deserve criticism. When do you
find someone who deserves all the hate
they're getting and much much more?
Encourage that hate. Feed it. Remind
yourself and others that it's perfectly
okay, good even, to wish all the worst
in the world on this guy and people like
him. You shouldn't just merely dislike
the man or simply disagree with his
opinions. You should hate him and
everything he stands for and represents.
Just facts. Just facts. So relevant.
Anytime you're watching Ethan Klein,
literally relevant. Anytime you're
watching Ethan Klein cry about getting
hate online, just remember that every
single mean comment he gets, he deserves
100% and then some for this scum [__]
behavior. And remember, Nicholas Dioro
used to go around saying all these
copyright threats and [__] going on
right now. We must not be doing our jobs
properly.
>> You know, listen, accountability comes
for all of us and uh can in Canada
especially. The crown the crown demands
The crown demands it. Did they do the
crown there? I think they do. They're
like welfare. Welfare of the crown. But
every every single comment talking about
how this guy abuses kids or whatever the
[__] regardless of their truth, he
deserves to receive them because anytime
you attempt to silence other people like
this through this sort of litigation,
any cost of success should massively
outstrip any benefit you could have ever
hoped to have gained. Any good outcome
you get from silencing that person
should be totally nullified and even
drawn into the negative by the amount of
negative attention you are getting from
every other angle. That is how it should
work. That is how it should work. When
you do this scumb [__] behavior of going
around trying to silence people like
this, it should be so [__] painful
for you. You love the queen.
>> I thought they have a prime minister.
Yeah, but no, but they're they're a
commonwealth
>> uh country. Yeah, they they still
respect the crowd.
>> They're part of the empire, bro. To
>> some extent.
>> It's it's just a it's like a ceremonial
traditional.
>> Wow.
>> Disgusting. What a disgusting [__]
wretching decaying old pervert.
>> Dude, listen. Um the crown is the legal
term for Satan government. Isn't that
badass? The crown. The court motions to
the crown to please [__] this man.
arrogant.
>> Yeah, he is sputtering into his bare
hands like a disgusting pervert. Yep.
>> Anyway, so that's what's popping in my
neck of the woods. Um, so yeah, that's
why I believe in my opinion Ian issuing
this apology and it just makes me laugh
because you can tell when he's saying
it, he's choking on it. It's like
>> it's crazy this stuff that like the
narratives that stick with people who
are on Snark. Like that's the same thing
that Mike from PA was harassing me about
when I went home from my grandma's
funeral and he was messaging me. Do you
have a comment on this? Do you have a
comment on on on Ethan not responding to
Destiny? It's like
>> muzzle the dog already. Muzzle the
[__] dog. I don't want to hear it
yapping. Muzzle the [__] dog already.
This whole like explosion.
>> Someone get the newspaper. I'm begging.
Get the spray.
>> Like don't you guys hate Destiny? Don't
you guys think he's like the most like
uncredible like [__] but now all of
a sudden you're parading around his
>> I mean it's obviously not in good faith
that they're not defending Destiny's
honor here or anything.
>> No, but but Exactly.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And that this is what I I
keep trying to warn these snark people.
It's not. You are going to [__] yourself
because you get you get in this snark
world and you think that you can just
say [__] like that and you can't. And
you think that like these snark mods who
tried to [__] who were now lost the
the whole um battle for the subpoena and
are now [__] bricks. Guess what?
Snark brain. It didn't have to be this
way. They're like, I'm scared for my
life. Really? Log off. I'm scared for my
life. My family never look at me the
same. Okay, turn off your monitor and go
outside. None of this happens.
>> So guys, this is what Ethan thinks. If
you use an anonymous account to talk
about things online, this is what Ethan
thinks should happen to you. If you're
being negative about someone else online
under an anonymous account, which I'm
sure all of you have done, Ethan thinks
you deserve to be unmasked, have all
that reported to your family, and be
fired from your job. And Nick Dorio
supports it. And Nick Doro supports it
as long as you've said something about
him before. Okay? Sorry, not if you've
said something about him. He supports if
you or anyone in a community you're in
has said something mean about him. In
that case, Nick Diori actually supports
you being uh doxed and out to your whole
family for [__] you said online under
anonymous account. I ha You don't
understand. I have to snark.
>> Son, this is what happens when YOU [__]
A STRANGER IN THE ASS.
>> I MEAN, WALTER said it. Walter walked so
I could run.
>> You see what happens? YOU SEE WHAT
HAPPENS, LARRY? Go on.
>> You see what happens? THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU [__] A STRANGER IN THE
ASH, LARRY.
>> I You know, you think Walter wanted to
do that.
>> This is what happens, LARRY. YOU SEE
WHAT HAPPENS, LARRY?
>> YOU for You force a good man's hand tan
there. This is what happens. You see
what happens, Larry?
>> Force a good man's hand. Over the line,
bro. Over the [__] line.
>> Can I point out that in this scene, he's
smashing the wrong's car?
>> No, you may not. [__] A STRANGER IN THE
ACT.
>> You may not
>> broke comes in. WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THAT'S MY CAR, MAN.
>> You You You may not point that out.
>> That's the best movie ever.
>> Uh a crown. May the crown strike that
from the record.
>> Yeah.
>> Man, it's been so long since I watched
that. I love that movie.
>> It's the best.
>> It's It is one of the best movies. It is
la.
Great soundtrack. Oh, what a wonderful
feeling.
>> I have a relevant question from from
Sarah Maria, actually, our Welsh fan who
we spoke to a couple weeks ago.
Question. Because YouTube is a
California based company, could they not
try and move the case to California and
say Canada has no jurisdiction? Explain.
>> Uh, the comment was made when they were
in Canada. Yeah.
>> Yeah, it that's my understanding. It's
it it matters where
>> Yeah. I don't know that we care about
any of this [__] [__] coping
about this. We'll watch her a bit more.
they are when they make
>> we'll just see we'll see if Zach has
anything Zach usually has some
intelligent comments to make like um
dude it feels like I'm in the Holocaust
right now
>> in their case they were in Canada
>> dude dude it feels like the Holocaust
dude it's like we're being holocausted
right now
>> I want a lawyer from there
>> Ian's being mean to him dude it's like
we're being holocausted right now it's
>> not some shoesting operation he's the
real deal dude anyway
>> it's like a shower it's like a shower
>> um and with that being said let's move
right along
>> chill queen ain't that serious ious bra.
Actually, I don't have a straightfaced
cat wiggler to switch to here so that I
can fully do the bit. But it does it is
actually that serious. It is actually
that [__] serious actually. It is
actually that bad. Disgusting old rich
perverts abusing the court system to
silence people's free speech is actually
that bad. It is actually that bad. We
used to think it was that bad. Everyone
used to agree it was that bad. But then
scum like the Oreo led everyone astray.
Scum like the Oreo spent a year, two
years convincing people that if there's
an anonymous forum talking [__] about
you, that's justification to sue and dox
anyone involved. That's what they spent
a year telling you, telling people like
Smaggle, telling all of that audience
that used to be principled around DMCA
abuse, around free speech online that
celebrated Idubbbz for his video, either
all of it's okay or none of it's okay.
Now crying about anti-semitism like a
bunch of neurotic middle-aged women.
It's absurd. It's [__] absurd.
>> He says nasty laser.
>> You're going to button you. Yeah, I'm
going to button you.
>> I didn't say it.
>> Thank you.
>> Didn't say it. I'm about to bust it un
bust.
>> Am I mod?
>> Only cuz you're here.
>> I was doing a s
>> the Syuno.
>> Yeah, that was another gross one people
couldn't handle.
>> Only cuz you're here.
>> Only cuz you're here. What happened? Is
there any updates to Syuno? What's he
doing?
>> Uh, he's gone.
>> Still busting.
>> He's just out.
>> He comes back. So miss him.
>> Last tweet four weeks ago looks like. O.
Yeah.
>> Looks like he's gone a wall since then.
>> I mean, he's
>> He'll be back. Don't worry. He'll be
back.
>> Only cuz you're here.
>> Okay. Well, it seems like all we're
getting out of that. Let's see a bit of
this guy being just a wretched pervert
in general.
>> Oh, so there was another drama that came
out of the um the poker game
>> and it has to do with our good friends
>> Itbs and Ana.
Uh which
very funny um coincidental thing
happened here. Let me show you this
story first
cuz she so she posted this on social
media
and she said I just got my [__] lasered
done by Shantel.
Okay, now I
>> literally it just should be the case.
I'm sorry but it sorry I'll get into you
know flaming this guy for being a
disgusting pervert in a minute. I'm just
stuck on his absolute just like moral
depravity. But it's just absolutely the
case. I think this is like literally how
it should work. And you guys can
disagree with me. Feel free to disagree
with this take. I think if you try to
sue someone over a joke about you
molesting your kids or something like
that and you try and silence them, I
genuinely think that joke should be
repeated so much that people honestly
aren't even sure if it's a joke anymore.
It should basically be if you try and
litigate a joke, it becomes fact. That's
that's basically how it should work in
my opinion is if you try to litigate a
joke, you try to make a joke essentially
illegal, it should basically become
fact. I think I think that's totally
fair. I think that's totally fair.
>> Didn't [__] want to know that. I
don't want to know what your dis [__]
nasty.
>> It should back it should backfire in the
most horrendous way possible for you
because it is just such a disgusting
thing to do.
>> Is this is about blazering your vagina.
And by the way, I saw her.
>> Let's listen to this guy being a
worthless pervert
>> first
cuz she so she posted this on social
media
and she said, "I just got my [__]
lasered
done by Shantel."
Okay, now I didn't [__] want to know
that. I don't want to know what your dis
[__] nasty business is about
blazering your vagina. And by the way, I
saw her later say this wasn't even a
sponsored post. She just said this [__]
cuz she's a she's a pervert.
She wasn't even right. She's the pervert
here. You're the one who sat around in
public stalking your ex-friend's wife on
your phone, taking screenshots of post
she's making about getting her [__]
hair lasered. And she she's the pervert.
She's the pervert. She spoke about a
laser hair removal. You're obsessing
over it and she's the perver. Aha.
Right. Yeah. That that I'm following. I
think I'm following. I think I'm
following. We come from the Nicholas
Dioro school of female interaction. I
see. Then been paid.
>> I don't think it makes her a pervert to
post it. But it is gross.
>> I mean, what would they say about me if
it's like, "Hey guys, I just got my
butthole lasered."
No. Hey, I just got all my pubes
lasered. I'm telling you for no reason.
It doesn't benefit me at all.
>> Uhhuh.
>> [__] to benefit the [__] business.
She shouted out the business, [__]
>> So, I saw this and you know me, I'm
always working. Always got my ear to the
to the tracks
>> when it comes to hating on these people.
>> Listen, and people go, "Oh, it's
>> You're not always working." I'll tell
you that. But
>> I mean, this Well, I sent this to work,
chat,
>> right? No, I understand. Yeah. Dude,
that's his cop out. Dude, that's his cop
out.
>> That's his copout for him looking at
this while he was playing poker. I I
sent it to work, chat. I sent this to
work, chat. Dude,
>> sleeping. That's the only time. But I am
dreaming about work, so I'm looking at
>> Where are you? Okay,
>> that's sometimes where I get my best
ideas. Um,
>> yeah, but
>> it doesn't change it at all. You're
still sat there staring at it, bro. What
do you mean,
>> bro? What are you talking about? I
literally told you from the get when
this whole thing started that I would
never leave them alone that I would
obsessively fall. I will never when
everybody's forgotten about them and
gotten over all
>> So So we agree you're a weird old
[__] pervert then. So we agree you're
a weird old obsessed pervert who can't
get this woman out of his head probably
due to some kind of frustration with
your ugly wife. I can only imagine. I
can only imagine it's sexless cuz no one
wants to hit that. I can only imagine.
That's all I can interpret. So you're
obsessed with this other guy's wife.
>> They're [__] I will never stop. I
will never stop. And so they're like,
"Oh, I can't believe he's say sending
her nasty [__] lasered [__] update
to it to the group chat and saying,
"Ew." Saying how nasty it is. Oh, I
can't believe it. Why
>> vagina,
>> I told you I was going to be doing this.
Tell Ana to don't post Tell Ana don't
post her [__] [__] updates on the
timeline. It's disgusting. Why' you do
that? I know you're watching.
>> It was so painless. I'm sad I waited so
long. I wish I laser my [__] sooner.
If you're in Edmonton, I highly
recommend it. Nobody's in Edmonton.
You're the only one.
Idiot. By the like 75 today. What's the
weather in San Diego? Every time I talk
about them, I need to do this. in
Edmonton,
Canada.
>> People in chat are pointing out that if
you lasered your butthole, you would
definitely let the world know,
>> which that does actually sound
>> Well, I wouldn't. Well, why would I do
that?
>> I mean, you probably just wouldn't do
that in the first place, but if you did,
I think you would let us know,
>> guys. I just lasered all my pubes.
I wish I did it sooner.
I don't know. Like I don't need to know
that her vag is [__] like I don't
want to know. It's disgusting. She
repulses me.
>> Female vaginas are disgusting.
>> It's 66 in San Diego.
>> Yeah. And also I just checked EMT. It's
actually really nice there right now.
It's raining but it's actually quite
warm. That's kind of
>> It's raining though.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Kind of freakish weather over there.
>> Well,
so um here's what happened.
my good friends over at the celebrity
poker tour.
>> Chinese girlfriend.
>> God damn it.
>> I feel like these cough drops make me
cough.
>> Chinese.
>> The cough button is helping though,
right? The mute button.
>> Very much.
>> It's very nice. Yeah.
>> Wait, did I hear the Chinese song? The
Chinese song. Where's the clip?
>> I just want a Chinese friend. Chinese
friend.
>> All right. What's you send me an album?
>> Yeah.
>> He just needs a Chinese friend. Okay,
Ethan. I am Chinese.
>> No. So, I am Chinese. I'll put it out
there.
>> Okay, Ethan. I'm Chinese. I come out
there. I come out here right now.
>> I
Chinese friend.
>> Um, my good friend.
>> I am Chinese. I come out there. thought
it would be a great idea to put a c to
show me my [__] phone in full view of
the camera and not tell me.
>> Aren't you not supposed to uh be using
your phone at the poker table?
>> No, it's fine. Most people do.
>> Don't post your cat emoji updates on
your timeline if you don't want me to
add it to my spank bank.
>> Jesus Christ. Thank you for the $4.99.
Thank you. Yeah, that that one
>> the game I played with uh Steiny, the
really high stakes cash game.
>> Mhm.
>> That one they confiscate people's phones
cuz there was like a weird cheating
scandal there.
>> Right. That's what I thought.
>> But no, usually usually nobody gives a
[__] if you're on your phone.
>> Was Vegas Matt on his phone?
>> Uh I don't remember.
>> So here's what happened. And I'll show
you this post from live stream fails.
People really got a kick out of this. So
here, let's watch. Wow, this really got
made the rounds. Okay, 16,000 points.
So people really got a kick out of this.
Um,
>> and you can imagine the dumbest loser,
snarker idiots. We're like, he's a
pervert. He's obsessed with her. He He's
psychosexually obsessed. He's
downloading and put into Spank Bank. You
can audibly hear me go gh when I pull it
up. And then in group chat, it's with
puke emojis. She is revolting. And by
the way, if you're like, "Uh, these guys
are talking about my pussy." It's like,
then don't post it.
>> True. Exactly. No, I agree.
I agree. You can talk about Ana's [__]
hair because she posted it. Just like
you can talk about how Ethan Klein's
kids got a disease that you can only get
through eating his [__] because Ethan
Klein said it. Because Ethan Klein said,
"My kids got a disease, but they can
only get through eating my shit." So,
let's all just say the most insane
things we possibly can about each other.
How about that, Ethan? How about that?
But no. But no, that that rule only
works for Ethan, doesn't it? That rule
only works for Ethan. You talk about
things he posts, that's a problem. If
you talk about, for instance, a Teddy
Fresh employee plagiarizing, you're
actually you're actually not
criticizing, you're doxing. I don't know
if you guys know this. That's not
criticism. That's doxing and harassment.
Okay, sure they post it online and you
can talk about it, but that's actually
doxing and harassment. You deserve to
have your family's wealth taken away
from you. You deserve to have your life
ruined. You deserve to be doxed and
kicked out of your school. It's [__]
absurd, man. Dioro has defended this for
two years. So, do not let him distance
now. I cannot reiterate enough. Do not
let this [__] loser distance now. The
only way this guy ever finds a path back
is a full admittance of lying for this
guy for 2 years. Don't post it to the
timeline and then act horrified when
people talk about it. Idiot. Dumbass.
Edmonton.
>> Come on.
>> Broke.
Repulsive. Here.
>> Look how they do me. Look how they do
me. You can see my whole [__] which I
just got lasered to the
>> I mean
number one
>> everything's neutral got both ready
>> I think they zoom in on it
>> congratulations to the either baby
number one
>> everything's neutral got both names
Yeah. Yeah.
>> You can see I screenshot. I crop it.
>> And guess what I'm going to do with it?
Send it to the [__] group chat,
>> dude.
>> Bro, I'm going to send it to group. I
wasn't saving it for later. I wasn't
saving it for later. I was going to send
it to group dropper. I swear it's for
research. It's for research.
>> For work.
>> It's work. It's work. It's grinder. Jack
off [__] Sorry. I know that that's what
they think I was doing, but I wasn't.
Yeah, exactly. I'd rather turn up like a
What was the whisper in Game of Thrones?
Aries. He was castrated. Doesn't matter.
>> Oh, berries. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh,
>> he didn't have dick or balls. Whole
thing cut off.
Um, so yeah, it's pretty funny. The
people in live stream fails got it. Now,
here, let me show you when I say gh god.
Listen closely here.
>> Congratulations to the Ecklers.
>> Baby number one.
>> Everything's neutral.
>> Oh god.
>> I'm repulsed. I'm talking to myself and
I'm so repulsed. It's almost like it's
it's a subconscious uh reflex.
>> Oh god.
>> I have it kind of isoed. It's not the
greatest sound bite in the world, but
>> Oh, God.
>> Do it again. Oh god.
>> That's how I feel. That's my That's my
knee-jerk reaction.
>> Yeah.
So, um yeah, the people in live stream
fails understood
um what it was. Uh you can audibly hear
him go, "Oh god, laugh my ass off." God.
>> Um for some reason, I thought the title
meant he was zooming in on the chick's
tits across the table from him and
taking a picture. Yeah, that would be
perverted.
>> That would be a lot more scandalous.
>> That would be [__] disgusting.
>> That would be right.
>> That's not what happened. I was just
literally on my timeline. It was on my
Reddit feed.
>> Not this though. This isn't perverted,
guys. This is what normal people do.
>> Yeah, I'm a dedicated
>> self-proclaimed dedicated hater. I mean,
[__] Day one. Day one.
>> Is that anything wrong with
>> this? My favorite reaction. Um, Carolyn
Quan, who is a lefty Twitch streamer.
Um, the girlfriend of uh, Hassan's buddy
Will, who by the way, Will's a nice guy.
No problem with him.
But she really, um, is very disturbed by
this revelation.
>> 3 minutes. God, can we
>> I didn't know it was this long. I'm
going to watch it for a minute.
>> I can't listen to these people anymore.
>> Just watch it for a sec just to see how
serious she takes it. She starts going,
"I feel bad for his kids." I'm like,
"Shut the [__] up.
>> [__] off.
>> The stands will still
>> find a way to defend it.
>> Um,
>> it's indefensible.
>> You're wrong.
>> It's indefensible. If this is what he
does when he's on camera, you know,
imagine what he does level of
>> obsession when he's off camera."
>> The same I do the same thing. I scroll
Reddit and then screenshot it and send
it in group chat.
>> I if if if Will I also the circumstance
Except, you know,
>> well, Griffin,
>> this uh beef that he has with Ana is so
absurd. But if Will had some
>> Who started it, Caroline?
>> Who started the beef?
>> I I didn't. I was really being really
nice and minding my own business.
>> Some woman.
>> Well, for the most part. I pro him a
little bit.
>> I can't handle these people.
>> First of all, I'd be like, "Goodbye."
>> So, remember guys, how did all this
start? How How did all this start
exactly? How did all this start exactly?
How? How? What happened?
>> How did all this Sorry. He was just
minding his own business. October 7th.
>> When you come out and say free Palestine
after they just lost everybody, that's
not what you should be saying right now.
>> And I'm free Palestine, too, right? It's
just the timing. I know what it is.
You're saying I support Hamas. I mean,
that's what you're that's what you're
saying. I'm just saying don't cheer for
terrorists. I don't think that that's a
crazy take. If you think it is, then
let's go invite the Iraqi terrorists who
are exacting revenge to come to your
city block and kill every [__] one
you love. If you think Hamas is dope,
just remember you deserve to be uh
burned alive by terrorists and your
whole family murdered in front of you.
>> Ethan's me when I'm minding my own
business. Me when I'm minding my own
business and avoiding controversy.
>> She would leave her boyfriend of several
years if he was caught
>> with some woman. Okay, first of all, I'd
be like, "Goodbye.
>> Goodbye.
>> What What's your [__] problem here?
What's going on?"
>> Mhm.
>> But second of all, if you were on camera
zooming in on on someone who is He's
clearly been obsessing over
>> Now, by the way, I'm not zooming on her
cleavage, right? I'm And I didn't zoom.
I was cropping it to be clear, dumbass.
Clearly trying to make it seem like it's
some sexual deviency or whatever. When
again, she's the one that announced to
the world she [__] lasered a [__]
Okay? If anyone's a sexual deviant, it's
her.
>> Her for quite some time. He
>> talk about the post.
>> Carolyn, how do you feel about people
announcing on social media and their
timeline that they lasered their [__]
>> If you say [__] one,
>> I can't help it. It's disgusting.
>> Only when you say it.
>> I say it because it I say it like it's
gross. It is gross.
>> Is this from a different episode?
>> I had crushes on all my t-shirts.
T-shirts. So this this is this is on the
same this was on the same channel
>> or Kate's Kate's the expert.
>> Great way of
>> this is deranged. Zach deranged and the
fact that it's on the same channel. Um
yeah. Well, do you have that blurred?
No, the one with their faces blurred.
>> Yeah. One sec.
>> Yeah. I don't want I don't even want to
get involved in I'm not even going to
show her public videos where the kids
I'm going to have more consideration for
her children than her. Right.
>> But you know that is life. pay your
bills.
>> Oh, yeah. And
it's crazy. It's all crazy.
>> Tight little body that I move school.
>> Bro, why would you call your
four-year-old fourth grade tight little
body? Even like if she's kidding to be a
provocator, this is like pretty [__]
demented,
right? I'm sure that's what she'd say is
that she's just being like a
provocative.
She's like, I don't know about this.
It's giving like
very bad vibes. where it was my ultimate
teacher crush, Mr. who was my sophomore
biology teacher and oh my god his
glasses and his muscles and his talking
and I would always go see him on my like
my breaks or I always like get out of
class and after go see Mr. Left my book
in his in his room and the seduction
just started. Now let me just say as a
disclaimer that I did not have sex with
any of my teachers till after I was out
of school and of age or college rather.
Uh I had a college teacher that I had
sex with who was my girl.
>> I I have the new um I have the new
soundtrack to um
>> to her to the family channel. It it's
more fitting with uh the fact that they
were on the same channel. not sexy than
any of my teachers till after I was out
of school and of age or college rather.
I mean, so he's he's playing footage of
Trisha with her kids with an old video
of Trisha talking about seducing her
teacher. I don't know. I'm not sure what
the joke is here, guys, but I would love
to hear Ethan explain it.
>> End of age or college rather. I had a
college teacher that I had sex with. He
was my girl.
>> I I have the new um I have the new
soundtrack to
>> to the family channel. It's more fitting
with uh the fact that they were on the
same channel.
>> Disclaimer, that I did not sex with any
of my teachers till after I was out of
school and of age or college rather.
>> I mean, it's on the same channel. What
I'm doing is not really even that crazy.
>> It was very easy to seduce him because I
had a tight little body.
>> Stop now. That's disgusting. Tight
little body. I don't care if it's about
yourself. You you were a child.
>> Stop it for one second. So, did you hear
what she just said right there?
>> I was like, that's that's the
commentator.
>> Okay. Did you hear what she just said
right there?
>> That's exactly what she sounded like.
Um, I did that and I think it was a good
joke, but it got so disturbing
immediately I had to close it. Yeah.
>> Um,
>> did not do anything with any of my
teachers.
>> And I'm I'm going to play that just one
more time so you can
>> Why does that sound like tomorrow doing
a voice?
>> Play that one more time.
>> That's you. Oh my god. This is you. You
made this video.
>> I did. I did. I really did.
>> No.
>> Um, but just to show you guys that this
is a video with commentary, right? and
remind you guys that when people were
actually stealing my content on Snark
subreddits and posting it for the
express purpose of stealing it when I
did a DMCA Reddit told me to kick rocks.
>> What the [__] Genuinely, you know, it's
like kind of ironic because I wonder if
>> they decline the DMCA.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> That is so I did not even know
>> one of these days.
>> I get Okay, not going to get sidetracked
by the
>> Wow, what what an awesome joke Ethan
just made.
Oh, beautiful. I can see into Diorio's
Discord again. Wow, what a world we live
in. I I got my eye in there. I got my
eye in there. Okay, so yeah, this a
disgusting pervert joke about Trish's
kids getting told by his wife and crew
to shut it down.
>> Wait, did she use the word [__]
>> Yeah. Well,
>> yeah. Use a cat emoji.
>> A cat emoji.
>> What do you want me to say?
>> I don't.
>> You want me to say cat?
>> We just get the idea.
>> Vagina. Yo, how crazy it would be if she
actually has a cat that she got uh
lasered.
>> That's illegal and g and that's even
more
>> Oh my god, that would be horrific.
>> I just lasered my cat.
>> Wait, what if that is what happened?
>> What if it was like a tumor or
something?
>> [__]
>> What?
>> You know,
I like to give people the benefit of the
doubt. Maybe maybe that is what maybe
that is what she was saying.
>> Some time now I be like you are unwell
and I I would not I don't want to be
with you. Mhm.
>> This is really creepy.
>> You hear that, Ela? It's time for a
divorce.
>> It's really gross. I don't care that you
don't like this woman.
>> Meanwhile,
>> you need to get a
>> Meanwhile, that screenshot was sent to
Ela.
>> Yeah, it was a group chat that included.
Yeah. I mean, we have, by the way, we
fished it up the screenshot.
>> Oh, dude. Let's Let's actually just sit
here and talk about how much of a
disgusting [__] the Oreo is and how much
I'm just like totally vindicated by
everything. So, this is um like over a
year ago, guys. This is well over a year
ago. You'll see here. Whoa. Leaked Nick
DMs. Rumor has it he's slobbing on H3
knob. Um, and this is a post with the
page griy DMs back in January last year
when they were shared initially. Um, you
see here Dario comments on it. I think I
actually discussed this on stream law. I
might have missed this. Can you or
somewhere else elaborate exactly what
you discussed? D's not here. Real one.
Pretty sure he's not banned from the
subreddit for being too rational. Ethan
is apparently DMCA posts on the hater
subreddit. I need the context of the
posts to make a judgment. He's saying
that's what Nick said. So guys, the
really interesting one here is this
tells you everything you need to know.
Okay, this tells you everything you need
to know about Nicholas Dioro and his
coverage. This one comment. Okay,
Ethan's haters have really worked
overtime to make me respect this [__]
guy. Why is one of Dioro's fans saying
that? Because the Oreo's reason for
everything is, "Oh, I don't know how I
feel about what Ethan's doing here, but
the people he's doing it against." But
the people he's doing it against. Same
for the Palestine people. Huh? You've
really gone out of your way to make me
appall your movement. Oh, what? So, this
Nick Dioro viewer loves Ethan Klein and
hates the pro Palestiny. Is that
possibly the message that you get from a
Nicholas Dioro stream is that you should
be pro Ethan Klein, pro- Israel? Is that
possibly the unstated message of a
Nicholas Dioro stream? That aren't these
lefties so insane? Aren't these people
so insane? All the normal people like
Ethan are cool with Israel and hate
these people. Is that not the unsaid
message of a Nicholas Dioro stream? And
you're a [__] idiot if you disagree.
I'm send it in the group chat.
Immediately send it in the group chat
for for work says I want to talk about
this on Monday.
>> [__] life. Yeah. Especially when
you're married with kids. It's like what
the [__] are you doing? I am very
familiar with misogynists
calling me calling me all sorts of uh
>> Do you think Nick's aware? Yes. Yes.
100%.
>> Who is this?
>> All sorts of
>> literally nobody.
>> No, she's not nobody. She's a She's a
>> She's a hater.
>> She's a leftist streamer. She's somewhat
popular and she's like the size of
denims and she's Will's
>> the size of denim
>> like in terms of like audience size.
>> And then I don't know what the [__] you
thought I was talking about. And then um
she's Will's girlfriend who co-hosts the
show with Hassan,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
what they, you know, what they view as
like the most humiliating, degrading
words that you can call a woman
>> and they think it's a way that
>> to end me and
>> I don't [__] Okay, now she's like and
yeah, anyway, I'm the victim. Shut up,
>> dumb ass. Well, actually, I cut the
part, my favorite part. I'll go to the
end, Dan, before you before you
>> before you freak out on me. I'm going to
go to the end when she gets way too
[__]
>> Figure it is behaving like this online
and
it's really it's vile and their friends
see it.
>> Yeah. Their friends see this kind of
stuff.
>> I can't remember. But essentially,
>> when you're when you are a person who's
a public figure,
>> okay, shut up. Anyway, I'll read the
quote. It says, "I just feel bad for the
kids. When you're a public figure, you
have kids. Guess what? Those kids are on
the internet or they will be. Not only
are they probably learning these
behaviors at home, they're also seeing
their parents or parent behaving like
this online.
>> Behaving like what?
>> Being a [__] awesome, funny,
hilarious dude with a cool job
role model.
I respect women, Carolyn. I don't know
if you know that about me.
I respect the [__] out of women.
And you know what? I'm gonna respect you
and say tata for y.
>> Very good.
>> Not gonna say anything more.
>> Gentlemen,
>> but just like imperfect like
>> just like what a disgusting reprobate,
man. Truly. What's this?
>> Let me know. You can see a redacted copy
of the PDF shared with the H3 Snarks
moderation team here. Oh god, they
provided everything. Reddit support re
your request sent to Reddit support.
This all goes over my head if I'm being
completely honest. Um, copyright owner's
full name, Ted Entertainment
Incorporated. So, multiple ones from Ted
Entertainment Incorporated. Okay. I
mean, they've provided documents, I
guess.